بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول
الله واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان
محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك
على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد يقول الله تعالى له معقبات من بين
يديه ومن خلفه يحفظونه من امر الله ان
الله لا يغير ما بقوم حتى يغير ما
بانفسهم واذا اراد الله بقوم سوءا فلا مرد
له وما لهم من دونه من
وال هو الذي يريكم البرق خوفا وطمعا وينشئ
السحاب الثقال ويسبح الرعد بحمده
والملائكه من خفته ويرسل الصواعق فيصيب
بها من يشاء وهم يجادلون في الله وهو شديد
المحال قوله تعالى له معقبات
له
الهاء الضمير
عائد الى الاسم الموصول في الايه
السابقه قال تعالى سواء منكم من اسر القول
ومن جهر به
من له معقبات يعني لهذا الذي منكم الذي
يجهر بالقول او يسر به او من هو مستخف
بالليل وسارب
بالنهار كل هؤلاء كل واحد
منا فان له
معقبات من بين يديه ومن خلفه يحفظونه من
امر الله
المعقبات جمع
معقبه
والمعقب
ملائكه
اما
معقب
فرض وجاء بالتاني مع ان الملائكه
ذكور ان الذين لا يؤمنون
بالاخره ليسمون الملائكه تسميه الانثى
اجمع العلماء اجمع
المسلمون على ان الملائكه ليس منهم
اناث
و لم ياتي
دليل في القران ولا في السنه على ذك كوريه
الملائكه ممكن جدا الا يكونوا ذكورا ولا
اناثا
ملائكه لا يولدون ويخلفون مثل
الانسان وعلى كل حال ما في من الملائكه
اناث ولكن الله سبحانه وتعالى يخبر عن
الملائكه تاره في القران بالتذكير وتاره
بالتاني والتذكير والتانيث في القران له
شان عظيم
كيف يعني
مثلا اذا
نظرنا
الى الذكر في الفكر
العربي حين نزول
القران فان العرب ينسبون الى
الذكر الى الرجل القوه
والشهامه
والشجاعه وينسبون الى الانثى الضعف
والرقه وما شابه
ذلك فاذا اراد الله سبحانه وتعالى في
القران ان يخبر
عن
الشيء بنوع من القوه فانه يطلق عليه
بالتذكير وبنوع من الضعف فانه يطلق عليه
التانيث
مثلا كذبت
ثمود ليش ما هي كذب ثمود مش ثمود
قوم ليش كذبت
ثمود
الله سبحانه
وتعالى يطلق على
ثمود بالتذكير
والتانيث خلاف في القران لكن
هنا كذبت ثمود بطغواها
كذبت
بالتاني وهذا التانيث يدل على ضعف
الحجه قال تعالى
كذبت يعني حجتهم داحضه ضعيفه جدا كذبت
ولذلك
اطلق على تكذيبهم بتاء
التانيث كذلك فانه سبحانه وتعالى يطلق
على الملائكه بالتذكير ويطلق عليهم
التانيث اولا ينبغي علينا ان نعلم
ان كل جمع في اللغه العربيه سوى جمع
المذكر السالم يجوز
الاطلاق يجوز الاخبار عنه
بالتاني يقول
الشاعر ان قومي
تجمعوا وبقتلي
تحدثوا ولا ابالي بجمعهم فكل جمع
مؤنثه يعني ان عده الشهور عند الله 12ث عش
شهرا في كتاب الله يوم خلق السماوات
والارض
منها اربعه حرم
منها لانه
جمع يجوز في اللغه العربيه ان تقول جاء
الرجال جاءت الرجال جاء الشيوخ جاءت جاء
الاشياخ جاءت
الاشياخ كل هذا
صحيح يبقى
الاختيار هل يطلق على الجمع بالتاني ام
بالتذكير على حسب
السياق هنا يقول تعالى له
معقبات معقبات جمع مؤنث
سالم
و معقبات
جمع معقبه
والمعقب اما جاء معقبه يعني جمع
معقب نعم فكان معقبات جمع
الجمع يعني له جماعه من مجموعه الملائكه
تتعقب وتتعقد
امره ويتعقب بعضها بعضا هذا قول قول اخر
جمع
معقبه وذلك لان
العرب اذا ارادوا ان يبالغوا في الكلام
اطلقوا على الذكر بالتاني واطلقوا على
التانيث
بالتذكير كيف يعني تقول امراه
حامل حامل ما تقول حامله حامله امراه حامل
للمبالغه في الحمل وتقول رجل
علامه بال التانيث لانه هذا
مبالغه فتقول فلان
علامه تقول علام
وعلامه
وامراه
حامل الى غير ذلك فعلى كل حال هذه
المعقبات جاء عند بعض العلماء
ان هذه المعقبات هي الملائكه وجاءت من
التعقيب
والتعقيب هو ان كل
ملك او كل معقبه من هذه المعقبات
فانها سموا بذلك لانهم يعقب بعضهم
بعضا ياتي هذا في عقب هذا ملائكه في في
النهار ملائكه في
مساء وقيل
معقبات هذا
يكون الملك من ملوك الارض له معقبات يعني
له حرس من بين يديه ومن خلفه يحفظونه من
امر الله وهذا قول ابعد وهو اختيار ابن
جرير على كل حال يقول تعالى له
معقبات من بين يديه ومن خلفه يحفظونه من
امر الله يعني
ملائكه والنبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم يقول في مثل قول الله تعالى ان قران
الفجر كان
مشهودا لماذا كان قران الفجر مشهودا يعني
صلاه
الفجر لان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
اخبرنا
بان الملائكه كل منا له ملكان في كل لحظه
من لحظات حياته من حين ان يولد الى ان
يموت ملك عن اليمين وملك عن الشمال هذا
يكتب الحسنات وهذا
السيئات
لكن اثنان في في النهار واثنان في الليل
في المساء في
الليل وذلك يكون عند صلاه الفجر وصلاه
العصر
ياتي دفعه
الملائكه
النهار على الفجر ودفعه
الملائكه ملائكه الليل على
العصر فاذا جاء
صلاه
الفجر اذا جاءت صلاه
الفجر
اجتمع ملائكه النهار
وملائكه
الليل
فكان قران الفجر
مشهودا
لذلك اذا رجعت هذه الملائكه الى الله
سبحانه وتعالى وهو اعلم بهم يسالهم كيف
تركتم عبادي
فيقولون جئناهم وهم يصلون وتركناهم وهم
يصلون يعني في العصر
والفجر لذلك
كانت افضل الصلوات صلاه الفجر وصلاه
العصر على كل حال هذه معقبات يقول ابن
كثير رحمه الله لكل انسان في كل
لحظه في اقل الاحوال اربعه من
الملائكه
اثنان
يكتبان احدهما عن اليمين يامر بالخير
ويكتب
الحسنات والاخر على
الشمال ينهى عن السوء ويكتب
السيئات واثنان من الملائكه
احدهما بين يديه
والاخر من
خلفه
يحفظانه من امر الله يعني بامر الله من
هنا بمعنى بامر
الله ليس معناه
انهم من هنا تسمى من يعني التي تدل على
التبعيض او تدل على
السبب يعني تقول خاتم من
ذهب ايش يعني خاتم من ذهب بيان الجنس جنس
هذا الخاتم من الذهب
ف يحفظونه من امر الله يعني بامر
الله لكن هذه
الملائكه هي من قدر الله اليس
كذلك
جاء احد الصحابه يسال النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم عن
الرقى عن الرقيه هل
تجوز فقال صلى الله عليه وسلم لما سئل هل
الرقيه تدفع من قدر الله شيئا فقال انها
من قدر
الله
يعني القفل على الباب بابك في البيت انت
بت تغل الباب في الليل هل هذا يدفع شيئا
من قدر الله نقول هذا من قدر الله اليس
كذلك
نعم
كذلك كل شيء الدواء لا يدفع من قدر الله
بل هو من قدر الله سبحانه
وتعالى وكذلك
الدعاء
ولذلك النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وسلم يقول
في حديث
عائشه لا يغني حذر من قدر يعني اذا جاء
قدر الله ما في درجه من من
الحذر تغني عن هذا القدر الذي قدره
الله فيقول تعالى له معقبات من بين يديه
ومن خلفه يحفظون ومن امر الله كيف يحفظونه
يحفظونه من الجن ومن غير
الجن ارايتم الجن
يستطيع اقوى الجن على الانسان نعم طبعا
الجن اقوى من الانسان ما الذي يمنع الجن
من البطش
بالناس هذه الملائكه
المعقبات التي بين
يدي احدنا
وخلف
احدنا فهذه
الملائكه تخت عن الملائكه
الزائده على
القدر الواجب لكل انسان يعني كل انسان في
كل لحظه من حين ان يولد الى ان يموت يولد
الى ان يموت فله اربعه من الملائكه في كل
لحظه لكن هل يمكن
ان يرافق الانسان اكثر من اربعه اذا كان
من اصحاب الخير اذا كان من اصحاب ذكر لله
نعم وكذلك لكل انسان في اقل احواله شيطان
واحد اليس كذلك كل انسان له
قرين حتى النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
الا ان الله اعانني عليه فلا يامرني الا
بخير هذه خصيصه للنبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
ف هل ممكن للانسان يكون مه اكثر من شيطان
واحد نعم اذا كان صاحب شر صاحب سوء صاحب
فجور
ف لذلك النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم احيانا
بعض اهل
ال اهل السوء الذين يريدون ان يردوا السنه
باهوائهم
ياتون بشيء من القران او بشيء من الحديث
الصحيح يريدون
ان يضربوا بعضه
ببعض فمثلا النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول لا تدخل
الملائك بيتا
فيه كلب او
صوره هذا حديث صحيح في
الصحيح في صحيح
مسلم فياتي هذا الذي يريد ان يرد السنه
فيقول طيب كيف الله يقول اينما تكون
يدرككم الموت ولو كنتم في بروج
مشيده قل يتوفاكم ملك الموت الذي وكل
بكم يعني الانسان اذا كان هذا الحديث
صحيح ان البيت الذي فيه كلب او صوره لا
تدخل الملائكه اذا ملك الموت ما
يدخل وهذا كلام كلام
باطل هذه شنشنه تشبه شنشنه
الكفار حين كانوا يستهزئون بالنبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم هذا ليس كلاما
علميا ولا
كلام يريد به صاحبه
خيرا وكان البخاري وكان الامام مسلم و ان
الائمه ما فطنوا لهذا الشيء اما هذا الذي
بعد ب 1500 سنه فطن هذول ما فطنوا ما
فطنوا للمساله
ها كانت الامه في ضلاله ثم جاء فلان من
الناس فاخرج هذه الامه من الضلاله بفطنته
وذكائه
وحذقه لا كثر الله من
امثالهم هذه ليست شبهه عند العلماء
لذلك العلماء لا يلتفتون الى مثل هذه
الاقوال واضح جدا باجماع العلماء ان
المقصود
بالملك لا ي لا تدخل الملائكه بيتا في كلب
او صوره يعني ملائكه الرحمه ملائكه الذكر
الملائكه التي تطرد
الشياطين واما الملائكه التي هي موكله
بالانسان فانها لا تترك الانسان يدخل خلاء
ليلا ولا نهار الا
وتصاحبه فعلى كل حال في حديث وهو حديث
موضوع مكذوب على رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم كانوا يحكوا لنا اياه واحنا صغار في
البلاد ان الانسان اذا قال حين
دخول الخلاء اعوذ بالله من الخبث
والخبائث فان الملائكه اللي بتكتب الحسنات
والسيئات بتوقف باب الحمام ما بتدخل
الحمام
معه فاذا دخل الحمام
وتكلم
دخل فاذا دخل
فوجداه
عريانا
لعنا هذا كلام مكذوب على رسول الله صلى
الله عليه
وسلم ولا يشبه هذا الحديث الموضوع كلام
سيد المرسلين عليه الصلاه والسلام ولا
يشتبه امثال هذه الاخبار الركيكه على
اقوال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم على كل
حال يقول تعالى له معقبات من بين يديه ومن
خلفه يحفظونه من امر
الله يعني يحفظونه بامر
الله
من امر الله ان الله لا يغير ما بقوم يعني
من النعمه
والراحه
والخير والصحه والسلامه ان الله لا يغير
ما بقوم حتى يغيروا ما
بانفسهم من الفطره او من الحسنات والاعمال
الصالحه فاذا تغير
الانسان وي فاذا تغير ما بانفس
الناس
تغيرت سنن الله سبحانه وتعالى بالنسبه له
يكون
هؤلاء على الفطره قوم صادقون صالحون فان
الله لا
يسلبهم ذلك الفضل وليس معناه ان الانسان
لا
يبتلى الانسان
يبتلى لكن نزع
النعمه على وجه ال على
وجه التذليل وعلى وجه العقوبه فهذا لا
يكون الا اذا ت ير ما بنفس
الانسان واذا اراد الله بقوم سوءا فلا مرد
له اي لا رد
له واذا اراد الله بقوم سوءا يعني
عذابا فلا مرد
له لا الملائكه ولا
المعقبات ولا
الانساب ولا شيء اذا اراد الله بقوم
سوءا فلا مرد له وما لهم اي لهؤلاء الذين
اراد الله بهم
سوءا من دونه يعني من غير الله من وال وال
يعني والي وهي قراءه
كالسابق وال ووالي في الوقف
والوصل قرئت هكذا
وهكذا وال
هو الذي يتولى
امره بان يشفع له
او يحفظه من الله سبحانه
وتعالى فاذا اراد الله بقوم
سوءا فلا مرد له وما له من دونه من وال لا
نبي مرسل ولا ملك
مقرب ولا ولي
مرتضى
وانما اذا جاء امر
الله فانه سبحانه وتعالى لا يرد باسه عن
القوم
المجرمين حتى لو كان الذي يجادل عنهم
ابراهيم خليل
الله قال الله تعالى
حكايه
عن ابراهيم عليه السلام في قوم
لوط فلما ذهب عن ابراهيم الروع يجادلنا في
قوم لوط ان ابراهيم لحليم اواهم منيب يا
ابراهيم اعرض عن هذا انه قد جاء امر
ربك
فحتى جدال ابراهيم وحتى شفاعه ابراهيم في
ابيه
فانها فانه لا يشفع فيه يوم القيامه حتى
لو انه ابراهيم خليل الله لو كانت له
مساله لو كانت هذه نافذه عند الله مع احد
من الخلق لكان مع ابراهيم عليه السلام الا
ان الله تعالى
يخبرنا ان من
سننه انه اذا اراد الله بقوم سوء فلا مرد
له وما له من
دونه من
والي نكتفي بهذا القدر والله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا
محمد
كن
11 سوره
الرعد
13 chap قران الله سبحانه
وتالى
ران
معق these are
angels which are constant taking each
other
place
and الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏the human being human
being has angels in front of him and
behind him to his right and to his
left protecting him and they were poed
by الله سبحانه
وتالى prot
being from that which not been deced for
that
ان سوره الله سبحانه
وتالى the
angels that each of us have two angels
one on the right one on the left the one
on the right commands us with good and
our good deeds the one on the left
prohibits us and warns us from doing
bad and
‏fr we have an angel and behind us we
have an angel from the moment we are
born until the day that the angel of
death comes to take our
souls each of us has a minimum of four
angels at
any الله سبحانه
وتالى
‏and that they follow one another in
their
posting meaning
that it is not the same exact
angel for 50 or 60 or 70 years
rather it
is a in the day
فجر عصر صل الله عليه
وسلم
صحيح الله سبحانه
وتعالى when the angels come back to him
the angels of the night they have their
rotation the angels of the
day
that they overlap
‏prayers of the day that when these
angels overlap with one another mean the
daytime
angels come to take
the their
shift
‏over so they are all at that moment
there and so if a person is
praying
عصر that when ang allen
be صل الله عليه
وسلم
الله the company of my servant so and so
such and such doing they will say when
we came upon him he was in pray and when
we left him he was likewise in
pray and so
these
‏some kind
physical
det
dang الله سبحانه
وتعالى
الله ‏ch stat of a
person or a people until they ch the
stat of that which is in their own
meaning that these angels yes they are
there protecting the person by default
when a
person الله سبحانه
وتالى takes the decision to punish any
particular person any particular people
‏these angels will not be able to stand
in the way of that
punishment and so this is a great
blessing that the person
has that he has these angels protecting
him since birth by
default
yet person ches what is in meaning he
ches
his he ches good with bad in
الله سبحانه
وتعالى state of being and his bless upon
person that
safety person has pry
to may ch that take that from a
person الله سبحانه وت
ت
الله then there is nothing that can rep
that
punishment there is nothing that can rep
punishment
transation تفسير
الله and des bad for people and there is
nothing that
‏des الله سبحانه وتعالى wills punishment
for a particular people there is nothing
and there is there is nothing that can
rep that punishment or protect that
punishment protect that person from that
punishment or shield him
prent
he
‏and people who have been
deci by
allah they will have
no as dispos aff bes
heci
‏from الله in الله سبحانه
وتعالى والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا
محد